تؤثر النزاعات والصراعات العشائريه
واستخدام السلاح على مختلف فئات المجتمع
العراقي سواء كانت لهم علاقه او لم تكن
الشاب المرحوم علي اكبر البياتي من منطقه
الشعب في بغداد راح ضحيه نزاع عشائري بين
عائلتين وتم قتله حيث كان فقط يمر بالمكان
الذي وقع فيه الحادث وهو واقف يعني
صدفه جيراننا يعني
علاوي شنو
هم دنيا
فشغل عبالك كان يعلم انه
[موسيقى]
القدر منتظر فتوجه البيت بيبي
يعني شلون هو كل مريض يقعد يمهم هاي في
العشر دقائق
ذاك اليوم ما لقى بيبيته
طلع راح البيت عمه
قريب على بيت بيبيته
يودعهم واحد واحد
والله صدفه ابن عمه
قلت لك انا يعني ابن عمه صار عليه
هذا فتح نار وهذا فتح نار وقع بيها
دقات العشائري
حقيقه في بعض النزاعات العشائريه لشاهد
العراق في بعض مناطقه حوادث مؤلمه
باستشهاد مواطنين لا سبب لهم حتى في موضوع
الاعراس او
الفواتح او ما يسمى لدينا في الجنوب
بالعراضه كانوا يستخدم هذا السلاح بشكل
كبير باطلاق عيارات ناريه في الهواء هذه
الافعال التي يقوم بها البعض ادخلت الرعب
في نفوس الناس وروعت الناس الامنين وتحول
الموضوع الى شريحه غاب يعني كل من لديه حق
يذهب وياخذ حقه بالسلاح دون اللجوء الى
المحاكم لذلك كان لابد لمجلس القضاء
الاعلى ان يتحرك لمحاربه هذه الظاهره التي
بدات تتنامى في الفترات الاخيره فنص على
ان هذه الافعال تندرج ضمن الافعال
الارهابيه التي نص عليها قانون مكافحه
الارهاب في الماده الثانيه منه حينما تحدث
عن الافعال التي تعد من الافعال الارهابيه
ومن ضمن هذه الافعال التهديد والعنف الذي
يهدف الى القاء الرعب في نفوس الناس اذن
الدقه العشريه تندرج ضمن مفهوم قانون
مكافحه الارهاب المنصوص عليه في الماده
الثانيه ويعاقب عليها بالاعدام حسب نص
الماده الرابعه من القانون ذاته